okay at this time I'm pleased to
introduce the moderator if I next panel
the experts speak the moderator is AJ
Kramer who is the federal public
defender for the District of Columbia he
has held that position since 1990 in
fact when the office first opened in the
District of Columbia he previously was
assistant federal public defender in san
francisco california for seven years and
prior to a subsequent to that he was
chief assistant federal public defender
for Sacramento California for three
years I'm pleased to introduce AJ Kramer
moderator for the expert speak panel
Thank You Nicky Jay I'm gonna have very
little to say and turn it over to a
group of far more distinguished people
than myself who I'm honored to be up
here with I do have just a few
introductory remarks I want to say I
think that my favorite quote on the
subject of racism or race prejudice is
by a person who's far more famous in
another field hg wells who said that
there is no more evil thing in the world
than race prejudice it justifies and
holds to get a more baseness cruelty and
abomination than any other sort of error
in the world and I really think that
that says it all in a very brief passage
we are now here I have been in the
federal public defender system for 13
years observing the incarceration of
young african-americans at an
increasingly alarming rate for longer
periods of time and more of them as
quickly as we can build prisons to fill
them the United States now incarcerated
at its peak the former Soviet Union
incarcerated one half of that number
Australia and prisons one-sixth of that
number and the Dutch imprisoned one
tenth of that number the incarceration
rate in the United States for
is 3,000 per 100,000 people while at the
height of apartheid in South Africa the
incarceration right of black rate of
black South Africans was 729 per 100,000
population that is a rate excuse me in
the united states of almost four times
the rate of incarceration of citizens of
color in 1990 the average sentence
nationwide in the federal system for
african-americans was over 120 months
over 10 years that is forty-nine percent
higher than the average sentence for
whites in addition african-americans in
the federal system are twenty-one
percent more likely to receive a
mandatory minimum sentence than whites
so I think what I have observed in the
past 13 years is in a sense a legal
genocide in this country of locking up
an entire generation of young
african-americans and while some people
I guess would applaud those numbers as
showing a great success in the law
enforcement field I think that it is a
national tragedy what is going on and
I'm pleased to be part of this program
focusing on this today I want to get
right to the heart of the matter let me
introduce the people who are here on the
panel to my immediate right is dr.
Marcia Lily Blanton who's an assistant
professor of Health Policy and
management at johns hopkins university
she's a researcher and health policy
analyst with over 10 years of experience
in research on issues related to the
epidemiology of drug abuse minority
health and access to health care for
vulnerable populations prior to joining
the faculty at Johns Hopkins she worked
as a senior health policy research
analyst with the US general accounting
office she has a doctorate in public
health from Johns Hopkins University to
my far right is Paul Goldstein who is an
associate professor in the School of
Public Health at the University of
Illinois at Chicago formerly he was
deputy director of narcotic and drug
research in New York City he has been
studying drugs and violence
relationships for the past decade and
holds a PhD degree in social
ology from case western reserve in
cleveland ohio to my immediate left is
dr. irene Jillson who is here as the
vice president of americans for
democratic action will speak on the
institutionalized racism in drug abuse
policy she has worked in the field of
Public Health and Social Policy for more
than 20 years she has worked in direct
services treatment and prevention
programs and has analyzed drug abuse
policies in the United States and
elsewhere has also prepared a national
drug abuse strategies for Jamaica and is
currently preparing an alcohol policy
statement she recently coordinated a
national drug abuse conference for
Americans for democratic action to the
left of her is dr. George Swartz who is
a physician a specialist in emergency
medicine and toxicology in the
pharmacology of drugs he is in private
practice in Santa Fe New Mexico the
author of many articles about drug abuse
drug chemistry and drug abuse he also
practices in California and as a
visiting associate professor of
emergency medicine at the Medical
College of Pennsylvania to his left is
Richard seltzer who is a professor in
the Department of Political Science at
Howard University teaches courses in
statistics and survey research and his
area of research is legal studies and
finally on the far left is Eric sterling
who is the president of the criminal
justice policy foundation a private
nonprofit educational organization that
promotes innovative solutions to
problems facing the criminal justice
system mr. sterling served as counsel to
the US House of Representatives
Committee on the judiciary for ten years
starting in 1979 his counsel for the
Subcommittee on crime he was responsible
for Drug Enforcement gun control money
laundering organized crime pornography
and many other issues he was a principal
aid in developing the comprehensive
Crime Control Act of nineteen
eighty-four the anti-drug abuse act of
1986 and 1988 and many other public laws
I do want to jump right into it and
start with you
dr. Schwartz yes what you born just one
brief interruption a special guest has
arrived and lord if you can just
acknowledge I just want to say that
activists comedian writer poet Dick
Gregory has joined us and he's just
going to say a few words he's in town
for the March and for the SCLC
conference and was just on the radio
this morning about the ease with which
young people are prosecuted and allowed
to participate in the criminal justice
system mr. Gregory first I think and
praise God that we've all here safely
today and let me say to the panel we
really thank you for your time and your
energy because basically this war is not
going to be run in the streets it's not
going to be one with the Polish it's
going to be one with the scientists the
same way when the world decided to need
a nuclear bomb it didn't go with
emotional folks that hated communism it
got the scientists and it put the right
money up and it came up with the right
documents in the right formula we know
that we cannot survive on this planet
without eating food and that comes from
planting but what we're going to have to
understand that the most fertile garden
that God ever put in this universe is
our mind and it's this mind garden that
your jobs is going to have to change
that with just simple simple arithmetic
don't give me algebra no gimme
trigonometry simple arithmetic and I
remember as a child going to the movies
I've never smoked a reef in my life
never been around hard drugs the
entertainer's and never in the history
have entertainer mated as high as I made
it and never food with drugs that's
because I was smoking full packs of
cigarettes and drinking a fifth of
scotch a day and what no room in my body
left for nothing else and and so but I
started because my heroes was doing it
and I think this is very important my
heroes was doing
the Earl Flynn's the Alan Ladd the
Humphrey Bogart couldn't say nothing
cool without a cigarette they couldn't
say nothing cool without a drink and so
I started it because of that and now I'm
61 years old I don't drink I don't smoke
I don't weighed 365 pounds or more and I
look back now and I realized that
Frankenstein never snorted coke and
wolfman never had a light beer and
Dracula never smoked a cigarette and all
of the things that I was afraid of
didn't violate their body and all of the
things that I admired and wanted to be
like did and so now we have to unwind
that and we have to unwind it and we
have to unwind it and now in between all
of this is the whole racist sexist piece
have have dropped in and it's very
difficult for my grandmother who's
horrified over the whole drug thing now
to have to be fin what's going on out
there because of the unfair sentencing
and and and what we have to do is go out
of our way to chop all the airlines away
because if you black and poor you see
things in your neighborhood that white
folks and and in middle-class black
folks don't see you see don't pushes at
four years old they point it out to you
that's that's a crack pusher that's a
crackhead and you also see the police
and they on the same corner and they
don't seem to be antagonizing one
another now I'm not here to say cops is
doing this or doing that I'm seeing what
a little child sees and then one day
that little child becomes grown and we
hear people say respect your local
police and that child keeps screaming
out how and every black person on this
planet even those that can't read or
write no we don't bring drugs in and we
keep wondering why is the killer
why is the penalty so high for the user
and seems to be so yeah it's
understandable you got a 30 thousand
dollar year prosecutor bumping into a
two-million-dollar case drug lawyer but
my grandmother don't understand that and
and I finish it by saying two things
drugs is really not a problem in America
that's a myth it's a fear and this fear
will destroy this nation every day 9
teenagers die in this country from
alcohol-related accidents as two women
who get raped do they smell whiskey or
crack cocaine on their breath and so
what I'm saying is we can stop it now
I'm not belittling the drug problem 465
Americans OD last year from hard drugs
in 51 percent of those OD death loss
prescription drugs but the only buddy
want to mess with the pharmaceutical
companies and so I'm saying that we have
a chance and thank you we have a chance
to roll out then to America let's stop
being afraid let's stop being afraid and
we african-americans are going to have
to stop having more fear for our enemy
then we have love for our children
without guns and bombs and nastiness we
don't have to go back and take our
corners back some of us might die but at
least you won't be innocent bystander
that's diet and finally if if all of us
on this panel with drug addicts and we
went to New York City today to turn our
self in because we don't want to do this
no more they would tell us there's a
waiting list we can't turn our self in
we sorry but there's a waiting list and
if i said to you my brother I live we've
all been drug addicts and we've been
friends but I have a special problem I
have a brain tumor and I have I have
pneumonia on my left side of my lung so
I can't wait another three months or
four months I have to get treatment now
how do I do it see that white woman over
there I'm gonna go hit her with a brick
and y'all make like y'all don't know me
grab me and hold me to the police get
there and they'll arrest me
they'll deal with my brain tumor I'll
get treatment immediately and their deal
with my new monia it is something
frightening living in a nation scary
that I live in a nation that out of love
I can't get treatment but revenge and
resentment there's no limit to the money
they will spend and so I say to you
ladies and gentlemen it's in your hands
it's about inflammation in its towards
way back when we start the nursery
rhymes Jack and Jill went up the hill
that won't keep me off of drugs Humpty
Dumpty we need to have nursery rhymes we
need to have wallpaper in the room where
the tots is growing up talking about not
scare tactic oh these youngsters is too
hip to deal in scare tactics now we need
basic information to go inside this
fertile mind garden and say this is what
drugs this is what alcohol this is what
nicotine will do to your little
beautiful body and I guarantee you will
win it thank you
thank you so much for sharing those
those remarks attorney Kramer let's go
and continue with the experts speak
thank you i still i remember reading
your book when i was younger and it
still has a lot of messages there's that
ring true for everyone i dr. Schwartz I
want to start with you tell it we heard
some debate this morning about the
relative dangers of crack as opposed to
regular power to cocaine can you tell us
what the difference is in physiological
effects in is crack a hundred times more
dangerous than regular cocaine okay just
start talking about cocaine and what it
is because what and as the Reverend
Jackson and I'm sure mr. Gregory and
everyone else realize that nobody here
and certainly not myself is for the use
of cocaine there's a very destructive
drug however we're talking about a
molecule which is used for medical
purposes of which there are 15 or 20
compounds cocaine type compounds present
in available medical use of those sort
the nature of cocaine is that it tends
to have varying solubility now the
cocaine hydrochloride which is mostly
used medically is soluble in water this
developed because of the need to use it
in medical procedures in the mouth in
the eye in the tongue and it became the
preferred method in addition in the late
1800s the water soluble form was used in
wines and coca-cola it's for example
this actually required a change from the
way it existed in nature in nature it
tends to exist more in what we call the
basic form which is fat soluble the
solubility and melting point become very
important in its later use because as I
said of the 15 or 20 compounds the
variation in fat or water soluble is
extremely important because when you get
to the what they call the base form of
cocaine this is when it's not combined
with a chloride and not combined with a
nitrate and not combined with anything
it tends to be lipid or fat soluble with
a low melting point this quality gives
it the ability to be inhaled because the
internal aspect
of the lung is lined with a fatty
substance such when at the low melting
point is vaporized it can go into the
lungs and rapidly go into solution he is
possible to smoke cocaine hydrochloride
it's somewhat more irritating it's
possible to ingest orally the base form
of cocaine and it will be absorbed to
some extent because of its fat
solubility but what we're talking now is
different routes of administration of
basically the same drug as a set of the
15 or 20 compounds the more fat soluble
it is the more it can be administered
through fatty sources whether injected
into the fat of the body or put into a
fat soluble medium the more liquid
soluble it is the more it tends to be in
insulated or injected intravenously now
when we talk about danger I'm very
distressed at something because I'm a
medical doctor I'm not running for
anything I have no constituency to
represent other than the basic medical
literature and I'm extremely disturbed
by the distortion of the medical
literature that is in terms of the
dangers mr. Farley this morning rewrote
30 years of medical history well how we
did that is that the overwhelming
majority of cases of problems are not
due to crack cocaine but the reported in
the medical literature are due to
insufficient scotch excuse me cocaine in
the sense of causing heart attacks cause
the absences quoting endocarditis
causing the entire range of medical
problems now there's not to say that
crack cocaine or the freebase form or
the fat soluble form doesn't cause its
share of problems however these even
less than fifty percent and it's a
mistake to think that the preponderance
of problems is caused by the crack form
of cocaine further it depends on which
window you look at if you look at it
from a societal point of view the
greatest danger to us now is the
intravenous form as it has been for
years because of the high incidence of
AIDS the acquired immunodeficiency
disease or the virus which causes AIDS
is found in between 30 and in some
places 60 and even seventy percent of
intravenous drug users
and if you're talking about cost factors
these people will actually impact our
medical care system with enormous costs
over the next 10 to 15 years if you're
talking about problems due to heart
attacks you realize the nasal insulation
route that is snorting causes more
problems probably because of its
sustained action originally when cracked
first came on the scene or which is
based better cold basic cocaine there
was a legion of physicians of preaching
a dire consequence from this substance
because it involved a route of
administration in fact this route is as
old as thousands of years when the
bushes actually put together into a
paste and smoked this is the common form
in which it's used in the Andes and in
South America however when it came into
America there was some dire consequences
predicted how do I know because I was
one of the ones doing the predicting and
I wrote a chapter in my textbook I'm the
editor of a principal textbook in the
field of emergency medicine in which I
indicated that crack from the
information I had available was going to
be causing major problems the difference
in the 1986 there are many physicians
who got up and spoke at various hearings
they have not recanted their testimony
despite the fact that time has now shown
very clearly that people choose their
routes of administration that the
inhalation route is not necessarily more
addictive that it is possible to have it
as a weekend or an occasional use it
doesn't necessarily lead to dire
consequences and destruction that over
the long term we have very little
evidence that it's more addictive that
the aspects of violence have not shown
clearly that any form of cocaine cocaine
and Ellie is by nature a drug causing
violence and paranoia but we have no
evidence that it caught that crack use
or inhalation use is associated with
necessarily any more violence than any
other form of cocaine and the Reverend
Jackson spoke about the ethical
responsibility and I'll point out that
there is an ethical responsibility of
the medical community who in 1986 or 87
brought forth dire consequences and
basically authorized a medically
sanction medically incur
aged lynching which affected black
people primarily based on incorrect or
inadequate or misleading information the
responsibility now is to correct
themselves and in some to some extent
that is exactly what I'm here to do you
touched on the violence dr. Schwartz
professor Goldstein you've done some
studies about the violence involved in
connection with crack trafficking and
cocaine trafficking is there a
significant difference in what kinds of
differences are there I think we have to
start back a few steps before I can
address that we have a problem in this
country and measuring drug-related
violence and defining what we mean by
drug-related violence before we get into
crack powdered cocaine distinctions I
think we have to address that issue what
is drug-related violence how do we
measure it we hear lots of estimates in
the media from politicians from police
chiefs twenty percent of our homicides
are drug-related eighty percent of our
homicides are drug-related I don't
usually know what that means and I
usually don't know where those numbers
came from with regard to the numbers did
they come for medical examiner's doing
forensic toxicology zhan victims of
violence and if that's where they came
from then we're just getting information
on victims we're not getting information
about the circumstances of crime we're
not getting information about
perpetrators did they come from police
when I've talked to police officers and
ask them about specific cases you know
was this homicide a specific case of
drug-related violence frequently they
would ask me well where did it take
place without you know I tell you having
you be an eleventh Street without
knowing anything else about the case
they say Avenue being Aleppo yeah yeah
it's drug-related crack because the
police pride themselves on their
knowledge of a community and they know
that that is an area where crack is sold
so if a hummus
I took place there it must be crack
related and I think we should consider
that in light of what was said earlier
about how the police may target certain
communities because I think that
targeting certainly contributes to our
estimate of the problem when people talk
about drug-related violence it's not
clear if they're including alcohol or
not is alcohol included in the
discussion of drug-related violence in
our society back in 1985 I published my
definition of drug-related violence what
I meant by drug-related violence and I
think it's become sort of a research
standard at this point you know when
people talk about drug-related violence
they generally acknowledged that you
know this is a useful way to look at it
and I say drugs and violence can be
related three different ways psycho
pharmacologically economic compulsively
or systemically psychopharmacological
violence can occur when an individual
ingests a substance undergoes a mood
alteration in acts out in a violent
fashion it can also occur when an
individual ingests a substance and acts
out in such a fashion is to bring about
their own violent victimization what's
referred to as victim precipitated
violence probably the classic example is
the loud mouth drunk in a bar who just
annoy somebody until finally gets
punched in the mouth he's brought about
his own victimization we have proposed
of psychopharmacological violence
individuals who want to do something
violent who planned to do something
violent but need a little help from
drugs to get over the nervousness of it
to boost their courage a little bit and
we also have violence occurring and with
regards to cocaine probably most if what
little psychopharmacological violence
seems to be attributed to cocaine it
occurs not so much from the euphoric
phase you know the early peek phase of
the use but it's a the latter end when
you're coming down when you're crashing
when you're feeling a little you know
depressed and irritable and if there is
going to be violence that's usually when
it happens and we have correspondence
with the withdrawal syndromes from
heroin where people are also nervous and
irritable and edgy and may act out
violently we also have economic
compulsive violence okay so
psychopharmacological is the first
category the second categories economic
compulsive you're strung out on
something expensive and you go out to
commit an economic crime to support that
use you may or may not intend to do
something violent it may happen you may
intend it but basically you're
committing an economic crime to support
costly drug use and finally we have the
category of systemic violence all the
violence connected to the system of drug
distribution the war's over territory
the deals gone bad the punishment on the
streets for selling bogus or tainted
drugs the drug deal or enforcing Norman
of order amongst the workers within his
operation okay so we have three distinct
types of drug-related violence now I've
looked at drug-related violence from a
variety of different perspectives in a
variety of different settings from this
perspective from this conceptual
framework we've done Street studies on
the Lower East Side of New York we've
done homicide studies statewide homicide
studies in New York State that we've
done City homicide studies in New York
City we've done prison studies the
talking with incarcerated murders this
research has been funded by the National
Institute on Drug Abuse and the National
Institute of justice what are our
findings and how does it relate to the
question today about the disparities
between powdered and crack cocaine well
first we find economic compulsive is
very rare economic compulsive violence
is very rare two to eight percent of all
the violence in all the different
studies is economic compulsive most
drug-related violence is either
psychopharmacol psychopharmacological or
systemic I'm sorry to interrupt you for
one sec we have another distinguished
guests who has just arrived and is on a
very tight time schedule I'm will get
back to you in just one second laura is
going to introduce the distinguished
guest that's just arrived
I apologize to both the panelists and
the audience for the way that we're
introducing these speakers but we have a
wonderful thing going on in Washington
DC which is the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference and the national
director of that Reverend Lowry is here
and has agreed to depart from his own
conference as well as I and an effort to
get arrested with mayor Kelly on DC
statehood in order to bring very very
brief remarks about his position on the
subject of the of our conference today
and Reverend Larry I want to thank you
for joining us comp this coalition with
us and for agreeing to say a few words
to this assembly in this audience our
experts from around the nation and
families who have been victimized by the
discriminatory law affecting crack
cocaine Reverend Lowery
thank you i feel so bad interrupting
this profound and and scholarly
presentation however i don't feel so bad
that i'm not going ahead and speak
apologize for interruption but we are in
the midst of a convention out in the
bird and the theme of our convention is
justice and then peace in the world and
in the hood and since we've been out in
rockville we've added in the burb so
that we are trying to tie the two
together I I thank the sponsors those
who took the initiative to pull this
very important assemblies together and I
told him I just wanted to come by and be
a part of it because we've been
concerned about it in Atlanta and across
the southeast and the nation since we
see young black men and now too much a
law degree young black women as well
being crowded into jails on the basis of
discrimination in this crack cocaine law
back in the talking about 30 30 30 years
ago at the march on Washington we were
planning the crusade against segregation
and discrimination and we really thought
all we had to do was get in the
mainstream we were in some kind of
little sidestream segregated side scream
and we just SAT off we can get in the
mainstream all our problems will be over
politically economically education
another way we can just get over in the
mainstream well we've been fighting to
get in the mainstream and and frankly we
are not all the way but we have made
enough ingress into the mainstream to
know something about its character and
what we discovered is as I try to say
last night a predator that the main
stream is polluted
ethically and morally polluted and so
another dimension is added to the
challenge and the movement is to purify
the stream because if you're in a
polluted mainstream what difference does
it make about all the struggle and
effort you put forward to get into it
when the pollutants are just as
devastating if not more devastating than
your prior condition and so one of the
one of the strongest most savage
pollutants of the mainstream today is
the criminal justice system I dare say
that one possible exception well I don't
know that sir but anyway no nothing is
more devastating to the african-american
experience and to pull people that our
criminal justice system needed to say we
have more black young men in prison than
universities but beyond that the system
has not kept pace it's at least a
quarter of a century maybe a third of a
century maybe forty percent of a century
maybe it's the whole hundred years
behind the rest of the country in terms
of progress toward racial justice in may
we help hearing in the Supreme state
Supreme Court building in Jackson
Mississippi about hangings in the
Mississippi cheers and have been some
almost thirty hangings in about 19 maybe
20 two months and even since we held a
hearing have been two instances of
african-americans being hung hanged I
never didn't know which was dr. we got
to hang hung kill would a rope around
a belt or something around that Nick and
and his called suicide and what we
learned in that hearing was really
educational about what's going on in the
criminal justice system in the state of
Mississippi and I mentioned the state of
Mississippi only because it's the only
one we've had to hearing so far on this
issue but what's happening is absolutely
shocking and disgraceful and it reflects
the trickle-down economic policies don't
but these other things do the same kind
of contempt for poor people that's
that's that's in this law 100 to 1 ratio
law is in is in our prison system
throughout and the criminal justice
system itself is a new slave master it
is the new lynch mob with badges and
black robes and sacred judicial chambers
that are that that is that is
persecuting poor people in this country
and this law is additional evidence of
the other disparities and and in
justices in our criminal justice system
what has happened in in in in the case
of Rodney King the only unique thing in
the Rodney King incident was the camera
I guarantee you we have in our office
records of Foley's cases of polio portal
de that we can't even respond to because
we don't have the staff because you
notice this is a post-civil rights error
what I understand meaning that we
thought we've solved all the problems of
right so no need supporting any civil
rights movement or the problem with all
themselves so in this post civil rights
era we don't have enough staff to
respond to the instances of police abuse
and and and and and and then to cop it
off the trial and the sentencing of of
[ __ ] and Powell and the vindication of
other officers give us further evidence
of what's happening in the new slave
mouth of the criminal justice system and
country then to top that off in addition
to the little tap on the thing worse
than that in my opinion was the remarks
of the judge a federal judge I
understand was appointed by one of our
prominent presidents Ronald Wilson
Reagan and he has a record I understand
where I got that from my chapter in law
says he has a record for stiff long term
appointments until our sentences until
he dealt with koun and Powell but his
remarks which has got to prejudice any
additional litigation that comes either
on appeal or sued by rodney king was
evident of the corruption and the
corrosion and the sinister nature of the
criminal justice system in this country
to date back to Mississippi jails we had
evidence of young man who was in
Philadelphia Mississippi you recall that
from the earlier days who was dating a
white girl and he'd been harassed by law
enforcement and and arrested on all kind
of interesting charges and
investigations and nothing would stop
men the the young white woman with whom
he was dating was her father was a law
and [ __ ] officer in a nearby County
and they were defiant of all the
pressures to break off the relationship
and he was arrested and shortly after he
was arrested the power failed in the
jail system just in one section of it
where his cell happened to be located
power fair we hadn't failed before in
300 years but it failed that time and
when the power did come back on a few
minutes he was hanged found hanged with
a belt and his pants didn't have any
belt loops because he never wore belt
but he was hanged and and the whole
system has has just swept out all the
indications of any wrongdoing in that
and and so I say this this this
disparity in this law is not an isolated
incident it is symptomatic of a criminal
justice system that is sick and that we
need to address with all the vigor that
we address that issue of voting rights
so I thank those who initiated this
conference Charlie Rangel is going to
introduce legislation we need to get
behind it with all the enthusiasm and
power that our resources afford to
eliminate disparities 101 ratio is
terrible that again I can't understand
any of the motivation behind this law
because we know who uses crack and we
know who's involved with powdered
cocaine and and and the truth of the
matter is the whole thing about the
marketplace for drugs has been
intentionally placed in the black
community because we're the black by the
marketplace is that's where the wall
zones going to be and while blood stains
the earth crimson in the black community
in the hood others enjoy or participate
in powdered cocaine with impunity and
immunity and I suggest to you that this
ought to be a top priority and for you
it is thank you for your interest thank
you for your leadership and I hope that
soon as we address this issue we can
continue to address the injustice in our
criminal justice system in the whole
thing about the administration of
justice in this country so that justice
may rule down with justice and roll down
with equity and respect and sensitivity
for the rights of all the citizens of
this country thank you very much for
this opportunity to say greeting I
apologize again to this distinguished
erinite panel who has permitted this
field niggra to come in and bring break
something into the house thank you very
much
I am going over now to get in jail on
the statehood issue pray for me that
thank you very much Reverend Lowery by
the way Reverend Lowery if you get
arrested there are some very fine public
defenders in the District of Columbia
I've seen your work never mind but but
we are free um I'm we had interrupted
professor Goldstein in his talk about
violence connected with the drug usage
in drug trade now I'd like to continue
on with his talk okay I'll try and wrap
up as quickly as I can because i know we
think we have a lunch and their other
panelists okay basically i was saying
when it comes to drug-related violence
it's primarily psychopharmacological
related to the ingestion of a substance
a mood change or its systemic related to
the drug business if it's
psychopharmacological seventy to eighty
percent of the time it's alcohol related
so I think the psychopharmacological
aspects of crack versus powdered cocaine
are not even that relevant to the
discussion when we look at the systemic
violence we find here is where we see
crack related violence in the business
end of drugs systemic violence has less
to do with the nature of any specific
type of drug its effect it mostly has to
do with the nature of the drug market
place and what particular phase in an
economic cycle that market happens to be
in we have if we look at our statistics
in our country yes there is a peak in
our homicide rate now in the late 80s
Early 90s that seems to be driven by
crack related violence if we go back ten
years there was another peak in our
homicide rate in the late 70s and early
80s that was driven by powdered cocaine
related violence the murder capital of
the United States today is Washington DC
or New York ten years ago the murder
capital was Miami Florida and if anyone
has forgotten what those years were like
you can probably catch some of the Miami
Vice reruns that are that are still on
TV there were wars between Cuban and
Colombia syndicates for control of the
middle level of powdered cocaine
distribution and when that war was over
when the Colombians won the homicide
rates dropped dramatically especially in
Miami um let me skip a few other things
I was going to say and just mention the
effect of police law enforcement
strategies on the incidence of violence
in our society the police I think are
well-intentioned they're responding to
citizen complaints they're trying to do
something about crack traffic but when
they engage in Street sweeps and
saturation tactics and different
communities when they arrest dealers
there are three or four other
individuals fighting to take that
dealers place and we have more incidents
of violence that occur and when the that
war is finally over in a new individual
has emerged as the dealer in that
community or on that street corner or
wherever the original dealer who is
busted is probably coming out of prison
and he wants his thourough Tory back and
we have some more violence so I think
the palm the enforcement strategies have
certainly been adding to our statistics
and with that let me stop because I know
our time is short talking about
statistics professor seltzer I know
you've done a study of comparing the
racial breakdown of crack punishment and
coke powdered cocaine punishment can you
just we've heard a lot of talk about
statistics can you run it down for us
what these statistics actually are the
US Sentencing Commission has who's in
commission for gathering data on people
sentenced under the otha sentencing
guidelines has only recently been
gathering data differentiating between
crack cocaine and powder cocaine but in
the last year in which they were able to
release data if you look at the data you
find out that the percentage of people
arrested for powder cocaine 27.7
sent in factored black if you look at
some of the other drugs for example
heroin we have forty five point seven
percent black if we look at marijuana
it's five point three percent black butt
crack cocaine happens to in fact be 91.3
percent black of those arrested and
convicted so you have a disproportionate
impact of arrest rates and the black
community for those arrested for crack
cocaine thank you dr. lily Blanton can
you tell us a little bit about your
views about the racial and ethnic
differences in drug use and the views of
an appropriate drug control strategy
given these statistics disturbing
statistic well what we frequently hear
and see through the media through the
movie industry is an image of drug users
who are unemployed we're standing on the
street corner for breaking into our
homes and yes of course who are also
black and Hispanic when you look
actually at statistics from the
household survey of drug abuse you see a
fairly different profile of other drug
users about 1 out of 10 Americans age 12
and older used an illegal drug in the
year preceding that survey most most of
those individuals were employed and
that's about sixty-five percent and most
were employed full-time most of those
individuals are white Americans use of
cocaine in the past year was reported by
an estimated six point four million
Americans most about seventy-three
percent were white Americans use of
crack a derivative of cocaine that
you've heard about today that is
generally smoked and sold in rock or
chunk form was used by about a million
Americans and slightly more than half or
white Americans and about 700,000
Americans reported past year use of
heroin and two out of three of those
individuals were white Americans
now some will consider these statistics
misleading since they merely reflect the
demographic characteristics of most
Americans however I present the
information as a way of having a context
for understanding the nature of a
problem as well as examining the racial
disparity and drug-related arrest drug
arrests per 100,000 persons in the US
are four times higher for African
Americans than white Americans and even
if you compare rates of drug use which
admittedly is the most appropriate
comparison you find that rates of drug
use don't differ substantially when you
compare African Americans and white
Americans whether the measure of drug
use is any illicit past year used past
your cocaine use or past your heroin use
there are racial differences in crack
cocaine use but in absolute numbers when
you're looking at those racial
differences you're still talking about
only a third of that population being
African Americans and ten percent being
Hispanics so when you compare the data
on drug-related arrest with the data on
drug use given you see a very good
indication that the law enforcement
efforts have selectively targeted one
segment of the population an inordinate
share of our drug abuse research dollars
has gone into counting the number of
drug users and describing personal
characteristics such as race ethnicity
such as age and gender and the
descriptive information is useful but in
many cases that information has been
used to reinforce racial prejudices and
stereotypes and to justify law
enforcement use of criminal sanctions
against african-american males and so
while the perception of the drug problem
is one that the problem is among people
who look like myself people of color the
statistics indicate that drug use cuts
across racial and socioeconomic class
groups white Americans face very serious
problems with drug use corporate
executives professional athletes and
entertainers health providers and many
other individuals who go to work every
day are among those who use illegal
drugs
I was invited to speak largely because
of some research that I was involved on
racial ethnic differences in crack
cocaine use and I'm not going to talk at
length about that but what we've done is
challenged the perception we've tried to
look and understand more about the whys
of racial ethnic differences in crack
cocaine use and in examining wise we
used a strategy that allowed us to look
at racial ethnic differences within
neighborhoods and within those
neighborhoods what we were holding
constant well what we call socially
shared characteristics or socially
shared conditions in an environment and
by that we mean conditions such as
social status we're talking about the
availability of drugs and we're talking
about community norms for dealing with
stress and when we did that when we
compared racial ethnic differences in
crack cocaine use we found that the odds
of use of crack cocaine did not differ
significantly when comparing
african-americans to white Americans or
Hispanic Americans to white Americans so
this research also challenges some of
the very widely held perceptions about
vulnerability to drug use and helps us
to refocus our attention and energy on
some of the factors in the social
environment which in fact the last
question you asked me is about what
should be our policy what is strategy
for this nation policy has been defined
as consisting of two parts and that
being the ends and the means and one of
the end goals of the war on policy has
been to protect the public from
drug-related crime and violence and to
achieve that goal the US government has
resorted to means that essentially have
been to break up the drug trafficking in
the streets it has been a flawed
strategy in many respects and it's been
a straw it's part strategy in part
because if I was trying to disrupt a
multi-billion dollar industry I wouldn't
focus on the least lucrative of the
markets I spend my energies trying to
intercede where the big dollars are
exchanged so we have a government
strategy that will likely have very
little impact on the supply of drugs
thus very little impact on drug-related
crime and violence and has resulted in
the incarceration of a sizeable segment
of the racial minority drug-using
population while essentially ignoring
the majority drug-using population now
the issue is what is an appropriate
strategy I have several suggestions even
if the system of justice in the US were
not racially discriminatory imprisoning
drug users whose only or primary crime
is drug use is a wasteful use of
taxpayer dollars prison costs in excess
of 20,000 dollars per year residential
drug treatment costs on average half
that amount several suggestions one is
our framework for addressing the problem
has to be totally shifted drug abuse is
a public health problem that requires a
lead response from the public health and
the drug treatment community that
doesn't mean that law enforcement isn't
needed laws regulations and their
company enforcement mechanisms are the
tools used by public health authorities
to protect the public's health and
safety concern about the link between
drugs crime and violence however has
been used to justify law enforcement
role in defining the parameters of how
best to address a public health problem
the resources and the expertise of law
enforcement officials are needed
particularly in efforts to reduce the
availability and the flow of drugs to
the US the problem is in the existing
balance in that relationship secondly we
need to shift the balance of the
resources so that the demand reduction
efforts and by demand reductions I
include drug abuse research prevention
and treatment are given at the very
least equal priority for funding two
thirds two thirds of our 12 to 13
billion dollar dollars of resources it's
now devoted to the war on drugs is spent
with international drug interdiction
efforts and domestic law enforcement
that balance has to
reducing drug use will require improve
knowledge more effective prevention and
of course treatment made available on
demand to drug users before before they
commit an offence and of course if they
commit an offense third when a drug user
has committed a minor crime or the only
offense is drug use drug treatment is a
more appropriate and a less costly
alternative than imprisonment clearly
this will require our distinguishing
between the drug users and those engaged
in drug trafficking statistics
unfortunately often combine the two and
make it very difficult distinguish
between who is involved in what but in
the case when a serious crime has been
committed appropriate treatment must be
available in prison the statistics now
provide some indication then that fewer
than twenty percent of those who are now
in prison with a drug problem are
receiving treatment this is one more
unconscionable policy that has been
allowed to persist for too long mr.
sterling
mr. sterling I guess the question for
you is having been behind the scenes of
drafting this legislation is did
Congress know about this tremendous
disparity we've heard about if so how
could they possibly have done it and if
they did not know about it why did they
not know about it and if they did not
know about how can we go about changing
it and why hasn't have been changed
already say in about two minutes can you
do it are you serious tective thanks
very much for giving me the opportunity
to to speak the criminal justice policy
foundation is very proud to be a sponsor
of this conference on and I want to take
this opportunity to thank the
Congressional Black Caucus foundation
which is providing major financial
support to this conference and to
Congressman John Conyers of Michigan the
chairman of the committee on government
operations here in the house which is
making this room available which is
provided invaluable support to all the
conference organizers on I also having
done a little work and seeing how this
conference put together want to thank
the hard workers Debbie Cohen and Alan
Huddleston travia Coleman and Ken
Brewster for the packets and all the
work that's gone into this um well
because I've been involved and I've seen
what's gone into I want to thank Terry
Garcia from the ACLU staff a Laura
Murphy leifer for all of her support and
of course Nikki cheetah Aoife who I
don't think is in the room right now but
um has a labored and labored and labor
to bring forth this excellent conference
uh the question you asked me is is a
question I've been asked to testify
about in federal trials in Atlanta and
st. Louis what did Congress have in mind
how did we get to this absurd state of
affairs and there are five points to
bear in mind to understand how the
incredibly unjust laws came to pass the
first was the driving power of partisan
politics behind these laws these are
driven by partisan politics the second
point was an extraordinarily unusual
legislative process
the third is to understand the
historically racist nature of the
cocaine laws as a specific example of
the racist nature of the drug laws the
fourth is to recognize that Congress had
a profile of crack sellers in mind and
that that was an unconsciously racist
profile and finally that it was not
rational with respect to the first point
on the partisan background in 1982
Congress passed a crime package
President Reagan vetoed it was a drugs
are attached to it and so he vetoed the
first congressional crime package of his
presidency in 1984 the president sent up
his own crime packages me in 1983 the
president's had his own crime package to
Congress but with the recollection of
his veto congressional leaders said well
we won't move a package will move
separate pieces of legislation but the
Republicans who controlled the senate
passed the president's package then
started attacking the democrats for not
passing the package after having made a
deal that there wouldn't be no package
and so throughout 1984 the democrats in
the house were being attacked for being
soft on crime and soft on drugs and
aiding abetting the cocaine traffickers
who were shooting up florida he would
have thought it was the Democratic
cocaine cartel from the kind of rhetoric
that was coming out of the White House
and out of the Senate which was
controlled by the Republicans and as a
consequence in 1984 the president's
crime package was offered as an
amendment to a spending bill an
emergency sub emergency appropriation
legislation that had to pass a called a
continuing resolution and with 20
minutes of debate on the floor of the
house the entire president's crime
package passed the house about five
weeks before the election five weeks
before the election we suddenly started
getting tough on crime well in 1986 we
have an election coming around again the
Republican control of the Senate is now
in balance
people are looking forward to the 1988
battle for control of the White House
once again and what happened was Len
Bias died Len Bias a star of the
University of Maryland Terrapins
basketball team Len Bias who just signed
with the NBA champion Boston Celtics
Boston being the home of the Speaker of
the House Tip O'Neill and he dies just
before the July 4th district work period
and the speaker goes back to Boston and
everybody's telling the speaker about
this terrible trike tragedy Len Bias
died how were the Celtics gonna retain
their crown it's an NBA champion Dean
what are we gonna do I mean isn't this
crap I mean if a star athlete like Len
Bias will die of cocaine how in the
world can anybody miss must be a
terrible drug do something about it and
the speaker comes back to Washington in
the summer of nineteen eighty six calls
the leadership of the house together and
says we're going to have an anti-drug
bill we're not going to be mal mouthed
by the Republicans on crime this time
we're gonna have a gigantic ônibus
super-new all improved you better
believe it's the greatest crime deliver
and I want it in 30 days on my desk so
that an extraordinary kind of process
commenced in one month the entire house
of representatives geared into war on
drugs high gear and one consequence of
that was we dispense with the usual
process of holding hearings to look into
what makes sense and so on the question
of mandatory minimum sentences there was
never a hearing on what that might be
there was never a review of the fact
that these laws had been tried in the
1950s and it didn't repealed by Congress
in 1970 because they were unjust and did
not work there was no review of the
mandatory minimum laws in New York which
had been a catastrophe for New York's
criminal justice system we simply
dispense with the with the with the the
usual process there was a panic-stricken
quality to that debate
there was no review of the historically
racist nature of these laws Reverend
Lowery a few minutes ago alluded to
lynching and it's important to recognize
that when the original cocaine
prohibition was being developed in the
Congress between 1910 and 1914 that was
the high-water tide of lynching in the
south in the United States and in order
to get the prohibition on cocaine passed
as part of the drug laws in the Harrison
act of 1914 there was a very conscious
effort to play a racial card hamilton
wright in his report to the for the
president spoke about how most of the
problems of the rape of white women in
the south were due to black men or in
cocaine the kinds of stereotypical fears
that we saw in 1986 weren't anything new
these laws are steeped in racial
stereotypes at that time it was said
well you know we we southern sheriff's
are gonna have to change our firearms a
32 caliber pistol just won't stop a
black man on cocaine we need 38 caliber
sidearms if we're gonna stop Coca nized
Negroes that historical record of course
was dispensed with as Congress raced
into this process but the fourth point
was what was the profile in the minds of
the members of Congress the profile was
young black men selling crack cocaine in
the streets of our cities and over and
over again the news media aided and
abetted in the creation of that kind of
profile into the Congressional Record
would be concertedly the columns that
reports the news stories every member of
Congress competed to be first insert
into the Congressional Record the latest
outrageous story about crack cocaine
Newsweek magazine in June had a story to
front page story about the crack cocaine
crisis and it starts off by talking
about the Trinidadian man wearing all
the gold who controls the crack market
then it tells about the Puerto Rican
woman who runs the crack houses
in New York and then they Haitians who
run the crack business and over and over
again there was a media portrayal and
therefore a profile created young black
men at large the level of rhetoric got
to the point where senator loren Charles
was would say soberly I seriously doubt
that America can survive crack cocaine
who eats a prot survived the depression
which the five McCarthyism would
survived World War two would survive
slavery but we can't survive crack
cocaine this is the level of the
rhetoric the level of the panic the
level of the hysteria that existed in
these rooms in 1986 and so what we had
was a process that could by no means be
characterized as rational there was a
contempt for rationality in the
legislative process I'll give you an
example are very our panelist earlier
rod um uh Terence Farley you spoke about
bullets and bombs you know which is more
serious and I immediately thought of
senator phil gramm's amendment koo
senator phil gramm had an amendment
dealing with bombs in the federal prison
prior to nineteen eighty six if you
possess the bomb in prison or a rocket
or a grenade or a loaded firearm you
could get an additional ten years added
on to your prison sentence as a result
of senator phil gramm's and Emmett and
Senator Graham knows a big advocate for
these mandatory sentences senator Graham
said let's impose a 20-year sentence for
possession of cocaine or heroin in
prison now is there a prison guard in
America thinks that the possession of
cocaine or heroin and in prison is twice
as serious as the possession of a bomb
in prison I'd like to meet that prison
guard that's the level of irrationality
there was driving this process and when
this when these comparative sentences
were pointed out the senator phil
gramm's death I'm sorry this has to be
in the bill this is the Senators part of
this bill the senator has to have his
part in the war on drugs there was a
contempt for rationality in the courts
Congress in 1984 created
rational sentencing scheme said here are
the ten factors that federal judges have
to impose in all the crimes across the
board the ink was not even dry and in
1986 or saying let's throw out that
rational scheme let's just look at the
powder on the table let's just look at
the number of grams did let's not
consider all those factors we just told
the courts to look at you know why
subtext judges are too stupid to figure
out how to impose a heavy sentence in a
big drug case we have to spell it out we
have to tell them you don't have any
choice judge this is a drug case we know
you're stupid now we let the federal
judges appointed by presidents Nixon
Ford Carter Reagan I mean we're talking
you know real let him loose types of
guys here confirmed by the Senate
confirmed by the Senate confirmed by the
likes of senator phil gramm a
republican-controlled senate from 81 to
87 those people can't be trusted those
federal judges in drug cases so we have
five grams as a mandatory five years now
the rhetoric was we want to send a
message to the Justice Department to go
after major level traffickers go after
the highest level traffickers we've got
very scarce resources here we want to
fight an effective war on drugs just as
as dr. Blanton just talked about go
after the high-level traffickers that's
what Congress had and they come up with
five grams and as a consequence the
tools at the Justice Department there
you look at the Congressional intent
five grams and you're bringing these
garbage cases that would be dismissed in
a state court into the courts of the
United States they're packing the
federal system and so rationality has
been dropped it was dropped by the
Congress and it's been dropped by the
Justice Department I don't think that I
could agree more
with that
doc dr. Jillson you have studied
institutionalized racism in the drug
abuse policy and I wonder if you could
give us your views of the rationality of
the disparity in the mandatory minimums
well we'll give you a little bit longer
I think we can take a little a little
bit extra time I don't want to cut
anybody else my time you took too much
as it was so I can make a comment
vitamin D um uh because I had to cut
down my remarks varies considerably let
me tell you that I did prepare a paper
rather lengthy paper and for anyone who
wants that you're more than welcome to
contact me or contact a cou and get a
copy because of time limitations and
because i think we've engendered a lot
of discussion hopefully on the part of
the audience I'd like to make just a few
points from this paper the first is that
we at Americans for democratic action
believe very strongly that the focus on
the criminal justice aspects of drug
abuse policy and its causes and
consequences over the last three or four
decades and certainly during the decade
of the 80s has resulted in and perhaps
been partly result of institutionalized
de facto and Asia a racism and classism
not just in the criminal justice and
drug abuse arena but in general in terms
of public policy we think is extremely
important to look at this issue broadly
in terms of public policy socio economic
policy health policy etc we think that
the data bear these out and the paper
present that but for purposes of the
next few minutes I'd really like just to
focus on what are the cofactors someone
prefer not to call them causal factors
of drug abuse and then look at what the
federal response has been to those
cofactors so I'm not addressing the
issue of the criminal justice system at
this point for nearly a quarter of a
century researchers in the field have
known
with a fair amount of clarity that there
are a number of factors that relate to
drug abuse that either exacerbated or or
caused it the first is family
dissolution or breakdown or trauma
spouse and child abuse and other types
of violence and I was very happy to hear
you mention observation of violence or
witnessing violence as a factor related
to drug drug of you said something that
we need to address very directly
unemployment and underemployment
inadequate health and social service
systems inadequate educational systems
and poor educational attainment and of
course the disproportionate arrest and
conviction for drugs and other types of
crime and then incarceration both of
youth and of young adults when all of us
know that the criminal justice system
can itself serve as a greeting breeding
ground for not just drug abuse but for
learning how to better trafficking in
drugs consistently racial and ethnic
minority groups and low-income Americans
who bear the burdens of racism and
classism independently or as dual
factors are significantly
over-represented among those who have
one or more of these risk factors in
essence these risk factors which are
interrelated work in synergy to impede
the ability of individuals to both
refrain from you either use or
distribution of illegal substances or to
benefit from any kind of prevention
programs which might be funded by the
government as a recent Carnegie
Foundation report notes the risks that
all young people face are compounded for
those who are poor members of racial or
ethnic minorities or recent immigrants
these youth generally attend the weakest
schools have access to the least
adequate health services and have the
fewest clearly visible paths to
opportunities in the mainstream and some
would argue to participation in the
American experiment in democracy I won't
go into the details of the statistics
you all knew them I'm sure let's look at
what the federal response has been over
the past decade primarily to some of
these cofactors given that we know the
relationship in
period 1978 to 1988 the federal budget
Authority for assisted housing decreased
from 30 1.5 billion to seven billion
dollars the Veterans Administration non
collegiate and job training programs an
important source of educational
opportunities for minority and
low-income Americans decreased steadily
from 440 million dollars in 1982 119
million in 1987 the Department of Health
and Human Services Social Security
post-secondary student benefit program
which has historically been a mainstay
of opportunities for low-income
Americans to pursue higher education
decreased from 1.6 billion in 1982 25
million in 1985 I'd like to point out
that this is at the same time that a
Defense Department budget was increasing
significantly as was the budget for the
criminal justice a specter drug abuse
policy in terms of federal expenditures
for drug abuse programs the increase in
expenditures for educational prevention
activities from nineteen eighty eight to
nineteen ninety-two rossum 232 627
million dollars but this did not begin
to address the problem the allocation on
the other hand this allocation compares
with 1.2 billion dollars of the total 12
billion dollars for drug abuse for the
Department of Defense 4.3 billion
dollars of the Department of Justice and
nearly a billion dollars for the
Department of Treasury even America's
overseas demand reduction programs which
are not which are ostensibly designed to
reduce demand in the united states which
have nothing to do with reducing demand
in the host country and which provide no
clear rationale for US policy receive
substantial amounts of funds for example
the agency for international development
in 1992 had 280 million dollars for drug
abuse programs overseas that's nearly
one half of the total u.s. prevention
budget even given the fact that this is
a rather paltry amount of money in view
of the problem what have we benefited
from this well some of us would say
sadly little let's look just at
treatment
dr. Blanton gave us some statistics on
estimated numbers of Americans who used
cocaine and crack in the previous year a
nest in that in the 1991 survey to which
you referred 1.9 million Americans used
cocaine in the month prior to the survey
and 479 thousand used crack in the
previous month the previous month is
something of an indicator of the extent
of the problem and perhaps the need for
treatment however in the same year
treatment programs in the United States
had the capacity to treat just over
750,000 people for any type of drug use
I repeat that for any type of drug use
clearly it doesn't begin to address the
problem of crack and cocaine but even if
we had treatment programs available the
literature in the field indicate that
we're really not quite certain what kind
of treatment is appropriate and there
are a number of people who fear that if
programs are six are significantly
expanded that will run into the same
problem we did with methadone in the
late 1960s when it went from a very
small amount of experimental study in
New York highly controlled to what some
called method on soda pop in the ad out
since the in the year since the outbreak
of the crack epidemic in fact scant
research has been funded to look at what
are the appropriate treatment modalities
some would say cynically perhaps that
the drug abuse industry has in some ways
flourished in direct correlation to the
drug problem and I'd like to to say at
this point that it's very clear to most
of us in the field that the drug abuse
industry which benefits directly or
indirectly from this 12 billion dollars
is predominantly white no question about
it and benefits universities the
consulting firms private research
institutions very little of this 12
billion dollars gets into the community
how can a nation spend 12 million
dollars on a drug control budget 19 892
alone
and have so little to show for it in
some ways the answer is quite simple the
United States has no coherent
comprehensive national drug abuse
strategy and in the absence of such a
strategy our nation's drug abuse policy
reflects the de facto and de jure
institutionalized racism and classism of
American society this racism is
pervasive not always subtle and exists
in the federal government itself I don't
know how many of you are aware of the
testimony given by dr. veni prim who is
the former director of the Center for
substance abuse treatment he recently
testified in Congress that racism is
rampant even in the very federal
agencies charged with responsibility for
reduction of the demand for drugs the US
government has historically lacked the
political will and the moral
responsibility to address directly the
forces that drive people to become
addicted to harmful substances
invariably our government responds only
when the quote drug problem unquote
reaches white middle-class America and
then the response is weak and meek and
does not address the underlying causes
which affect disproportionally
african-americans Hispanics and poor
Americans clearly we have rarely if ever
confronted the reality of the racism
that permeates governmental drug abuse
policies and programs this would require
not only an understanding of the complex
interrelated nature of drug abuse and
other socioeconomic factors but the
courage on the part of those in
authority to confront the reality
confronting this reality however is we
believe a sin qua non of formulating
international drug abuse policy and is
urgently required thank you very much
thank you very much I've been
I've been told that we can take one or
two questions before I close it up if
there are any questions I'm sorry I know
there's probably a lot of questions but
we have time for one or two or maybe
there's none anybody having ok I will
just wrap it up by saying that in my 13
years as a in the federal public
defender system I have noticed a
vindictiveness come into the system that
was not there at least in great form
when I began I have witnessed the
federal prison system triple in the past
decade to where it is now at a hundred
and seventy percent of capacity and the
Bureau of Prisons is a single largest
part of the Department of Justice budget
now over half about 50 to 250 three
percent of the offender's going into
federal prison our drug cases and I just
want to wrap it up by saying I want to
thank everybody who was here on the
panel if anybody thinks that anywhere
close to more than a tiny majority a
tiny minority of the people going into
the federal prison system are anything
more than very low-level poor vastly
over-represented minority drug users and
people involved with drugs there are no
kink there are there are some kingpins
going into the federal prison system but
very very few and all you need to do is
come and observe our office or a federal
public defender office which handles the
vast majority of federal criminal cases
are going to the federal court system
for a week or two and see what kinds of
people are actually being sent to
federal prison Thank should sure I'm
it's it's a quick lolipop would quickly
just one of the problems has been the
interpretation of grams I think we'd go
around the room and find out that many
people have no idea what a gram is and
just to give you an idea of what a gram
is a teaspoonful weights about 5 grams
what you find in a packet of sugar on
the table it's generally about five to
seven grams so when you talk about an
individual being caught with five grams
of the substance you're talking about a
teaspoon full of the substance and and
and that needs to be interpreted in
vantage point of personal use versus
distribution use and there's no
discrimination in the law regarding the
nature the biochemical nature of this
neurotransmitter substance what it's
being used for I just want to add a
thing because I you know I want to get
it down into real terms the actual
amount so that people can understand why
these laws are very strange they have
been five years for a teaspoonful of an
illegal substance in an 18 year olds who
has made a mistake in judgment but the
penalty is so extraordinarily severe
thank you to everybody on our panel
appreciate I'm sorry we took so much
time
ok